une reine des votes une souveraine
peintre une dame passionnée par la chine
des goûts personnels que marie leczinska
exprimées dans ces appartements
officielles et privées
c'est donc la première qui aménage ce
qu'on appelle les cabinets de la reine
les petits cabinets et des espaces où
elle peut se retirer pour lire pour
méditer pour effectuer des travaux
d'aiguillés pour peintres puisqu'elle
était peintre à ses heures
1 marie leczinska à rennais 42 ans sur
la france le règne le plus long à
versailles
fille d'un roi déchu de pologne réfugie
en lorraine
elle devient reine après des pourparlers
il faut savoir que le roi louis 15 est
d'abord fiancée une petite infante
d'espagne la fille de philippe 5 qui est
marie anne victoire de bourbon
simplement quand le roi arrive à un
certain âge il a une santé fragile et on
se dit que sa petite fiancée et bien
avant lui donner des enfants il faudra
attendre bien des années et finalement
on va décider de renvoyer cet enfant en
espagne et on va choisir une future
reine qui soit à la fois catholique est
en âge de procréer peu mise en avant au
sein du château au profit de
marie-antoinette marie leczinska a tout
de même laissé un héritage retranscrit
ici à travers une cinquantaine d'oeuvres
et d'objets
[Musique]